I for sure but I would bet you for sure
they're in north of a hundred million in
subscription revenue what do we got I
want to talk about talk about this idea
I'm gonna idea it's a company arsenic
yeah they've been around for about four
years now yeah I know I don't know how
they're doing do you know if they're
doing what they were doing okay
basically the way that I knew some like
media people who talked about them and
knew them and I'm almost positive that
it's run like it looks like it's run
which is a bunch of kids who are good
looking and rent the mansion and they
just dude right so that debauchery so
the idea is arsenic is essentially
playboy for the snapchat generation and
so they have a snapchat channel because
you know the idea is like okay Playboy's
big deal what would playboy be like
today it would not be a magazine it
would be you know a snapchat channel and
so they created the snapchat channel
which is perfect cuz it's like if you
follow it you get it if not it's not on
your face so it's not like like Facebook
would be a little weird
Instagram would be a little weird and
they have email too and they just have
this mansion and they have all these
models and it's not porn but it's
definitely models we're good looking and
they just have one model like sort of
take over the channel least as what it
was three years ago I just think there's
a great idea they raised three million
bucks I don't know how they're doing so
they've got books they do like tours I
think that it could be doing a the ideas
it's a cash cow I think hmm
well I because they were getting
millions of views back van on their
videos I can only assume it's grown
unless snapchat blocked him but they're
not outside the bounds of what's not
allowed that channel I was porn right no
they don't lap horn but they nudity they
don't if you're putting on your stories
you'll get banned eventually if you're
doing nude if you have a baby they don't
do nudity
what's that up for a private account you
can eventually if it gets flagged
they'll take it down like it's not in
the rules to do nudity well that's far
sign have you heard of only fans yeah
love it
so explain only fans only fan so
basically what happened is on snapchat
all these porn stars were putting up
like porn yeah like softcore porn I
don't think it was like sex but like pay
me ten dollars and I'll let you follow
me right and you'll fall on my account
where I post nudes and only fans
launched and what they
it was it was a platform where they I
don't think they started with porn but
now it is that yeah yeah so just embrace
it but basically if you I don't even
think it's porn I think it's like web
girls and webcam girls and you pay $20
however much they want you to and you
get access to their private video feeds
yeah it's like patreon but porn
basically yes you pay you become a
contributor and then you get their
private photos and videos it's taken off
has it yeah and the reason yeah because
I was do it like who cares if I consume
it or not from a business point of view
that's how I know about we all care and
I mean no surprise like yeah but so
here's you know why I think these things
take office the people who don't take
care of the creators they they they for
these types of things they they go away
yes and so there's always demand so the
demand is always there the question is
does the platform allow the supply to do
what they want to do and the big
platforms don't do it it's not worth
their brand and risk and all the stuff
because the only fans I for sure but I
would bet you for sure they're in North
of a hundred million in subscription
revenue and then they take their cut
that's insane at one point in time well
we had a we had blab like live streaming
product and it wasn't working we had to
pivot and we pivoted adventure to video
gaming but I definitely laid out a case
to the company that investor I was like
look porn is the porn is where the
source would be the best like these
they're not [__] on camera I don't
think ok well whatever you want to call
it like softcore porn or whatever but
like going after the sort of the cam
girl market is a pretty it's a big
market and the websites that are there
really really suck and so so what sounds
like man said well we have kind of a
heart-to-heart we're like is this what
we want to build and my co-founder felt
a certain way the investors felt a
certain way what did FERC on want to do
um he was like not down to that I'm so
down with that yeah so I think it's you
got to make a personal choice then I've
had a bunch of entrepreneurs reach out
being like hey we saw you did blab we've
read your post mortem you guys got to
four million users but it didn't work I
have a very similar concept I think it's
gonna work can you give me some advice I
tell them from the bat jump I'm like
this version is not gonna work
consider porn I think it could work
consider the cam girl angle because you
know that's the one stone we didn't turn
when we were considering you know where
to pivot this thing to make it I would
prefer do that because thick all these
like patreon all the [__] they're like
we're gonna empower creators okay I'm
behind that but even though a lot of
times I think they don't but if you're
gonna empower creator imagine this like
woman who can just crush it by not
breaking the law and just using her own
body
I'm philosophically I'm so in favor of
that right yeah I think as a business
person I'm definitely in favor of it I
think it's just a personal possession I
love it it's just like a human being I'm
like yeah
[Music]
you